your stance on washing your hands after
you piss I don't do it
my is clean Will Smith said this to me
he didn't wash his hands after he pisses
either shout out to Will Smith we're
leaving the ABC bathroom we both took a
piss together this is 24 years ago he
came up to piss next to me and I got gun
shy right and I couldn't piss because he
has a huge he has a fire hose of urine
coming out and he's just pissing next to
me and he's going let me tell you the
key to Hollywood and I can't hear
anything because all I'm thinking is
just start pissing just start pissing
but I can't because this is so loud and
I have a dribble of a piss and I have to
piss so bad so I just push push and I
start pissing it all I hear him saying
is advice is uh be yourself that's it
that's it so I get done and I don't wash
my hands and I turn around and I think
it's a root of connection and I go hey
you don't wash your hands off your piss
I don't wash my hands after pissed he
goes much clean let's go and we walked
into a room and sold a TV show
it's clean